good morning it's 5 48 in the morning
the paper towns movie starts filming in
like 1
hour and 12 minutes i'm extremely
excited and nervous wait
something looks different oh i got new
glasses no that's not it
oh it's the creepy mustache i've been
setting that joke up for more than two
months when i ordered my new glasses
they were like it's gonna be eight to
ten weeks and i was like
perfect i'll grow a beard all right i
have to shave i can't let the movie
people meet me like this by the way
relevant t-shirt
look hank i have my own chair so people
keep asking me what an executive
producer does
i don't know i just listened to the
headphones and uh i get a chair with my
name on it
and i think that's it hey guys all right
so this is nan wolfe he played q in the
movie we just started filming that's not
weird
just keep doing that that's the kind of
thing it's great thank you
thanks for being in my video today okay
this is like the only place i can film
outside
without giving away our location it's a
nice brisk day here in north carolina it
feels just like orlando in april so hank
i was just literally jumping up and down
with jaz sinclair who plays angela in
the movie because this is all just like
so exciting and wonderful and amazing i
can't i'm gonna have to do my happy
dance but i'm holding the camera so it's
gonna look a little weird also there's
like
40 people in the crew you know who are
going to watch this but whatever i'm so
yes how do they look good all right i'm
gonna go back inside radar's house now
which is full of black santas i wish i
could show you the black santas there
are literally thousands hey there's so
many things that amazing about movies
like the incredibly expensive cameras
but the thing i will never get over is
the quality of the porta-potties i mean
look at this is this a porta-potty or a
mansion
for god's sakes it's got hardwood floors
tank we've now left radar's house when
we find ourselves
by a pond that's all i can tell you i
just wanted to quickly comment on your
great video about being a young person
and not voting when i was a young person
i did not vote a lot
like i missed several elections that in
retrospect were pretty important to
american history and i missed them
because
well mostly because i was like nervous
and i didn't know how to vote so i just
wanted to say to anyone
who's like me and really nervous about
like the prospect of voting for the
first time
i understand that it's a little bit
scary but once you do it you're gonna
feel
awesome hank if it looks a little darker
that's because it is a little darker
because we just finished day one
huzzah producer wick godfrey how you
feeling
huzzah that seemed fake but it's going
well i think i got back after the end of
a long day and look
look look i have a trailer i have my own
trailer it's got the fancy hollywood
lights
oh man this couch is so comfortable i
love being an executive producer i want
to be an executive producer for every
movie does the new divergent movie need
an executive producer
because i am available no that reminds
me of how much i miss shailene and ansel
but
i am so so excited about this i think
one of the scenes we filmed today was
the first part of paper towns i ever
wrote i wrote it like nine
years ago and it was just so weird and
wonderful to see little q
and little margot biking up to this you
know
dead body sounds weird when i put it
that way but anyway it was wonderful i
cried a little but to be fair i cried a
lot on movie sets
crazy crazy crazy thanks to everybody
involved in the paper towns movie hank
don't forget to vote nerd fighters in
america who are over the age of 18.
don't forget to vote
and don't forget to be awesome i'll see
you on friday